hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear and this is going to be
the last review for monster march i was
actually going to do another theme for
april i was going to do anthologies but
then i thought to myself i think that
april and may i might just like leave
them wide open so i can do whatever
movie i want to do because there's a
whole bunch of new ones that got added
on shutter and on some different
streaming services that i kind of wanted
to catch up on and i didn't really want
to worry about having to fit them into a
theme so i think i'm going to move the
theme like the anthology theme to maybe
august because it starts with a and i'm
anal retentive like that uh so yeah but
i am gonna have some themes every now
and then but i think that because i had
a theme last month and this month uh i
think i'm gonna cool it with the frame
with the themes for the next couple
months so i can catch up on some uh new
and older movies that i wanted to review
that didn't necessarily fit into the
theme that i had imagined
but since this is the last one for
monster march you knew that i had to get
around to doing this one eventually and
i really really had been wanting to do
this when it's been requested a couple
of times and this is the 2006 monster
movie the host uh south korean film
directed by bong joon ho who obviously
uh won you know worldwide acclaim and
oscars galore with the movie parasite
from 2019 which is an excellent film he
also made a snow piercer
he also made memories memories of murder
which i love i should probably get
around a review on that one of these
days too he also made one called okja
but i haven't seen that one yet i've
seen all his other ones and they're all
fantastic
and much like his uh other movies and
like a lot of korean south korean movies
in general at least ones that get like a
wide uh western audience
they're very very adept at like mixing
different genres so while this is a
horror movie and a monster movie it's
also kind of like a family drama and a
satire and it's really really well uh
balanced like you can just watch it as a
fun monster movie obviously but then
there's like a lot more depth to it as
well and you get like really involved in
all the
family relationships they're very i mean
korean movies in general as i said at
least the ones that tend to get wide
releases over here are just really good
at not only making a great horror movie
but also kind of like tugging at your
heartstrings and getting you to like
really care about the characters that
are in the movie like i'm thinking of
like trained to busan and stuff like
that which actually legit like kind of
made me cry at the end but uh this one
it's kind of the same i mean this one i
don't know if i won't necessarily want
to spoil the ending this movie's not
that
uh not that new i mean it's 2006
but i'll try not to like spoil the end
too much i don't know how uh how widely
it's been seen like how if you guys have
seen it i will say that it does have
a bittersweet ending so it's like it's
sad but there's like some happy stuff
too that's like all i'm gonna say but um
i actually kind of liked it i mean the
ending is kind of a bummer
but i'm kind of glad that it had sort of
like the balls to to end it like that
you know what i mean but yeah we'll get
into that a little bit so again this
came out in 2006 this was actually bong
joon ho's
third movie i think he'd made one called
barking dogs never bite that was his
first one i think that was on shutter
for a while i don't know if it uh if it
still is and i still oh that's i haven't
seen that one either then memories of
murder which like i said if you haven't
seen that it's great and that's like a
police procedural
and uh then this one which is like a
monster movie
now this movie
was actually inspired by a true event
which happened in 2000
and apparently there was a guy who was
like a korean uh mortician's assistant
and he was working for the u.s military
in seoul korea
and they apparently his superiors told
him to dump all this formaldehyde like
down the drain which would send it into
the river and then that it had caused
some like kind of minor mutations so
that's kind of where so the opening
scene of this movie where herschel from
the walking dead the aka scott wilson
uh where he is kind of like the military
guy like he's like a like a pathologist
like a military pathologist and he tells
his korean assistant hey like we're not
using all these old bottles of
formaldehyde anymore so just dump him
down the drain at which point his
assistant is like um that's gonna go
right into the han river which probably
not such a good idea and he's just like
[ __ ] it just do it anyway you know what
i mean so it seems so if you see the
scene and you're almost it almost kind
of like shades over like
like cartoon villainy kind of thing but
just know that that's pretty much
exactly what happened in real life um it
didn't cause like a huge monster but it
did cause like some smaller mutation so
it's not really that much of an
exaggeration
uh so so yeah that's how the movie
starts uh you have this all this
formaldehyde being dumped into
directly into the han river and then it
jumps ahead a little bit and i kind of
like that it does this because
this that first thing happens in 2000
and then they jump ahead a couple years
and then there's like a couple fishermen
who are fishing in the river and then
one of them like picks up a thing and
they're in his cup like when they're out
fishing and like you can't see it they
don't like it they don't show it to the
audience but he's just kind of like what
the hell is that thing you know what i
mean
how many tails does it have so it's
i like that they showed that it was just
kind of like started out as like this
little small thing that could like fit
in someone's cup
and then being like wow that's funny
looking or whatever and then it kind of
like gets away and then like as the
years go on like you're led to believe
that it just gets bigger and bigger
so uh so aside from the monster kind of
the heart of the story is the park
family
now
the main guy i guess he's like like i
said it's kind of like a family drama as
well but the main guy is named uh gang
do
and he's kind of
not a stupid guy but he's just kind of
like a schlubby kind of not excessively
bright kind of lazy you know what i mean
so he works in his dad's like food stall
they have this food stall that's on the
han river and it's kind of this it's
kind of this like pavilion or this place
where like a lot of people come like for
picnic and
picnics and stuff so he just works in
the
in this food stall and uh looks like he
just spends most of his day like
sleeping he's like just kind of sleeping
so his dad's always just kind of like
get your [ __ ] together you know what i
mean
so there's that um so gang do also has a
little daughter named hyun sio
and she's probably about she looks about
11 or 12 to me i'm not sure if they said
like how old she was but apparently what
ended up happening was that
i guess her mom like ran off and
so now uh she's kind of been in the care
of this
not so bright dad and she's and she's
kind of like you can tell that she's
like a lot more precocious and like kind
of a lot smarter than him
and uh so there's that now sometimes she
gets babysat by
uh her aunt and uncle
who are gangdo's brother and sister
so he has a sister named namjoo who is a
she's a uh like an archer and she's
because they show her like at the
beginning like she's doing like some big
competition and like she only wins the
bronze even though she was you know in
line for the gold and she like you know
she choked at the last minute so you
know that's gonna like factor into the
story later on
and then gang do's brother is named um
nam ill and he's like a college graduate
but he's been having a hard time finding
a job so he's kind of like alcoholic so
in the so in the middle of the monster
action you kind of have this family
dynamic where there's kind of a lot of
resentment and other things going on in
this like they love each other but
um you know there's they have they all
have their own flaws and they all have
their own issues that kind of come into
play as the story goes along
so
one thing that makes the host different
from a lot of monster movies i feel like
most monster movies and even like the
great ones like jaws and stuff like that
they don't really i mean they really
really hold off on like showing the
monster like a lot of times they'll just
kind of show hints of it or if they do
show it it's kind of like in the dark or
it's shadowed or something like that um
the host does not do that pretty much
maybe less than 10 minutes but i don't
even think it's 10 minutes of the movie
less than 10 minutes in the movie that
big monster has jumped out of the river
and is like running in broad daylight
and is like running down [ __ ]
running down the riverside uh with
everybody screaming and running around
which was a really again like a very
audacious
move like for a monster movie and i
don't really i'm sure there's been other
ones that did that as well but
i kind of feel like it was just really
that's really really different like for
a monster movie that it just like throws
the monster like right in your face like
in the first act of the movie like only
a few minutes in now this was 2006 and
the monster is completely cgi
so the cgi looks slightly dated but
honestly that's really not i mean it
looked amazing for the time like for
2006 so it's actually like some of the
best monster effects you had going for
2006 which nowadays like i said you
can't really help
you know that it ages out some but it
still
looks pretty god damn good i actually
watched the host on i think hulu
and uh you know they have a nice version
on there and even though obviously you
can tell it's cgi some of the times when
it's moving and stuff like that but it
still looks pretty god damn good
especially for the mid-2000s christ
knows i've seen lots of horror movies
that came out in the early to mid 2000s
where the cgi just looks like complete
ass but this actually looks really
really good
so the monster
i like that the monster is kind of it
looks like a monster it's not massive
it's not like you know kaiju size it's
basically like about the size of a bus
or something like that but i mean still
big enough that it could eat you and it
would like it's still scary
but i like that they made it look like a
monster but look almost like a
believable
mutated monster you know what i mean
because it has
kind of like
if a fish and an earth like an
amphibious animal like maybe like a frog
kind of tadpole situation but if it kind
of got mutated so that it kind of looked
fishy but then it still had legs and
then it also has a really interesting
like prehensile tail
so which is good because then that gives
you another kind of thing where it can
like grab onto things matter of fact the
first time you see the monster
everybody's kind of like all the
picnickers and stuff like that are like
all along the river and they're like
what the hell is that thing because it's
almost hanging
like a bat or like a cocoon or something
like that like from its tail like
underneath the bridge and it's kind of
all curled up so nobody can tell what it
is at first they think it's like some
big construction equipment like in a bag
or something like that they don't like
think it's a monster like whoa what the
[ __ ] is that and the hilarious thing
about it too is that at first when they
see that it's a creature and that it's
alive um you know it kind of like
unfurls and then it like goes in the
water and then it starts kind of
swimming over to them and nobody is
immediately alarmed everybody's just
like hey neat it's like it's an animal
like at first they kind of think it's
maybe a dolphin or something like that
although i don't know how they would
explain why it was hanging upside down
under the bridge because dolphins
generally don't do that but at first
they're like trying to feed it like
they're throwing like food in the water
going hey neat but then like it jumps
out and they're just like oh [ __ ] and
then they all start like running away
so yeah so it's mass panic mass chaos
in the chaos where everyone's trying to
run away from this monster gang do who
up to this point like i said this is not
that far into the movie but up to this
point you there's been enough
characterization to realize that gang do
is kind of seen as like the loser of the
family like he's just lazy and he just
like hasn't made anything of himself and
he's just like you know sleeping in the
in the food shack and it's like when his
dad asks him to do something like hey
grill these squid for these people and
it's like he [ __ ] it up and you know
what i mean so he's just that kind of
like schlubby not overly bright kind of
dude but to his credit he does really
kind of like
man up like almost immediately because
like i said his daughter is around and
he doesn't want her to get hurt
obviously so he actually goes him and
this american guy are trying to like
fight the monster and like trying to get
it from you know to keep it from eating
people and [ __ ] like that so they do
actually like try to fight against it
when everybody else is kind of running
away but after a while like the monster
is just kind of rampaging knocking
people over like you know kind of
swallowing people so he decides well we
just gotta get the [ __ ] out of dodge so
he has his uh his daughter uh hyun
hyuncio he has her by the hand and
they're running and running but then
there's like all this chaos and then he
kind of turns around and sees that the
girl whose hand he's holding is somewhat
is a different little girl uh so it's
not his daughter anymore so then he
looks back in horror and sees uh that uh
that hyun so is back there and that the
monster like basically picks her up with
the tit with its tail and you know kind
of snatches her away and then goes jumps
back into the river with her so
obviously they presume that the little
girl is dead
so there's really a funny scene i was
watching the horror show earlier like
there they did like a 20-25 minute
discussion of this movie uh they're both
big fans of it and it's funny because
one of them said well the first time i
saw this movie i think i didn't realize
that the grieving scene like where they
because like i said they think the
little girl is dead so they're all in
this like big kind of like gym or
warehouse and they have all of these uh
morning pictures like all the of all the
people that got killed by the monster
with like little black bands on them and
they have like flowers arrangements and
stuff so like the whole park family is
in there
and they're all like uh freaking out
like at this
it's like funny because it's sad because
you know you think the little girl is
dead
but the way that they're just like
overreacted they're just like wailing
and like rolling around on the floor and
stuff like that and so like what and i
think the first time i saw this because
i've seen this movie like three or four
times and i think the first time i'm
like i'm pretty sure that's supposed to
be funny that he's like big because you
know i didn't i think when i first saw
this i didn't know a great deal about uh
bong jino's other movies but he does
have like a kind of like dark sense of
humor like that so i think that even
though yes it's sad because like the
little girl is dead and they're mourning
her but i think he was kind of like
making a little satirical jab at this
kind of like
like this over-emotional where they're
all just like i said just rolling around
the floor and screaming and stuff i mean
i thought it was funny and i was just
kind of like i'm pretty sure like he
meant it to be funny and i don't know
maybe that's like kind of a cultural
because i think that's one thing the guy
said too he's just kind of like he's
like now that i've seen more korean
movies i get that he's like kind of
making a like a dark joke about it but
at the time he didn't realize that it
was like kind of supposed to be funny
he's like is that are we supposed to be
like sad because this is like kind of
hilarious that there's like rolling
around like that but yeah so they think
that she's dead and then um everybody
comes in like the military and
scientists and everybody like that and
they're just kind of like okay well
this monster actually carries a virus
hence the name of the movie the host and
if you've had any contact with the
monster
then we need to put you in quarantine
because you're gonna get some kind of
like fever or rash or whatever now
because the whole park family what ended
up happening was gang dude didn't touch
the monster but he did kind of like hit
it with um with kind of like the bottom
concrete bottom of a sign or something
and he kind of like got some of the
blood splattered on his face so he tells
them that and they're just like holy
[ __ ] and so they have to bring him in
the whole family and they put him in
quarantine
now while they're in quarantine though
uh gang do gets a uh phone call like on
his cell phone which was actually his
daughter's cell phone um she had given
they had had an argument because he's
like didn't have a lot of money and he's
been like saving up all this change so
he can buy her a real cell phone because
this is like an older she's like i can't
even get a signal on this [ __ ] thing
you keep it so it's his daughter's cell
phone so he gets a call while he's in
quarantine and it's his daughter being
like hey you know i'm alive i'm gonna
sue her somewhere but the signal isn't
good enough for them to like figure out
where she's at
so now that they realize that the
daughter is actually still alive
they kind of have to like rally like the
whole family and they're like we need to
get the [ __ ] out of this quarantine
and go find out where she is she's still
alive someplace so that's basically what
the most of the middle part of the movie
is is them attempting to get out of
quarantine attempting to like run away
from the authorities you know they have
to
go to these gangsters and like get
weapons and a truck and all this other
and you know outfits and stuff so they
can like you know do all this subterfuge
so there's all that kind of stuff and
then they don't know
where she is because she just says i'm
in this deep sewer someplace and so they
have to like do all this stuff to try to
triangulate like where the they have to
like go to this dude and like figure out
where the signal came from so they can
find out where she's at so there's that
kind of thing too the great thing about
this is that the sewer where they shot
all the scenes with the little girl and
there's a bunch of other bodies too
because apparently what the monster does
is because you see him like eating
people like in the opening scene where
he's like rampaging around the riverside
like all the k all the picnickers and
stuff
and what he does is he'll kind of like
eat him but then he
keeps him like in his stomach for a
little while i guess and then he takes
him back to this lair which is like a
sewer pit and he like regurgitates them
down in there and then later on so i
guess he like keeps him in there like so
later on he can like snack on him at his
leisure but that's what he does so
that's why some of the people that get
dropped in there are dead but some of
them are still alive including um
pyeongchao
so she's down in this sewer which
actually i think at first they were
planning on
building a set like for this sewer but
they found one that was exactly like
what they wanted like a real one like a
real like sewer pit kind of situation
and they're just like oh how 4-2 it is
so they decided that they uh we're gonna
film it in there so uh they had to take
a lot of precautions obviously because
this is actually a real
sewer water sluis or whatever the hell
it was so they're just like yeah they
had to give all the cast and crew like
tetanus shots and they had all like wear
gas masks like when they weren't on the
thing so you know it probably wasn't a
fun situation and they said it was like
cold as [ __ ] down there you know what i
mean so uh but but it lends the movie
like a lot of varus militant obviously
because they this poor little girl
like crawling around in a real [ __ ]
sewer pit i'm just like man she's a
trooper i gotta say
but yeah so so it's basically like a
race against time uh for them to find
the little girl like what sewer she's in
uh before the monster actually eats her
because like i said he does he just eats
people and like regurgitates them back
in there and then eats them actually
later and then later on he comes back
and like regurgitates like a whole bunch
of bones and [ __ ] so he's like a whole
bunch of bones i mean he's really really
been eating his vlogs what i'm saying
but yeah so like through the course of
the movie as i said it's kind of like a
family drama it's it's like it's a
monster movie and it's scary and tense
but it's also like funny like darkly
comedic uh at times and it also has a
lot of
really good kind of like drama as i
don't even know if i'd call it drama
because a lot of it is kind of still
dark humor
but it is kind of showing how
sort of this family is who were kind of
fractured are being brought together
um through their hunt for hyuncio
and also how each of their
flaws kind of almost contributes to how
they end up defeating the monster at the
end you know what i mean like because as
i said each of them has their kind of
flaw whereas like the uh namel the one
brother who's kind of like an alcoholic
who's unemployed and he's very resentful
about it and then you have namjoo who is
you know kind of an elite athlete but
keeps not being quite good enough
because she doesn't like release the
arrow quick enough like she's too slow
you know she's just too slow and so she
just wins the bronze like at the
beginning instead of the gold and then
you have gang do who is kind of like
this shiftless
not terribly bright kind of like lazy
who feels like he's not maybe doing
enough for his daughter
so you kind of see them rise above i
guess rise above their flaws and kind of
like uh get over each other's like their
resentment for one another because
there's like this funny scene and it's
like it's funny because it's like
touching but it's also like hilarious
where
they're kind of all in this uh little
food thing where they're kind of like
stocking up on food while they're
looking for uh looking for the sewer
and uh the dad is like uh gang do has
fallen asleep again like that's another
thing like he kind of sleeps all the
time i guess they're trying to say like
lazy but i was like does he have
narcolepsy is he all right but yeah so
he's like always falling asleep and
they're just like jesus christ so he can
sleep at a time like this but so the dad
is like talking to the other brother and
sister
and it's like do you really think that
gang do is that pathetic and they're
both like yeah
you know what i mean it's just like
really funny like of course
and then he kind of goes on and tells
them he's like you know why don't you
basically cut him some slack it's like
you know when he was because he's a
little bit the gang dude is i guess a
little bit older than the other two and
it's like you know when he was younger
like you know
he didn't have a mom and it's like i was
out carousing and like i left him home
alone all the time but it's like he had
to go out and steal food because i was
you know out and drunk and i wasn't
taking care of him and you know it's
like he's got a lot of problems and it's
like you know why don't you just like
again like
cut him some slack because he didn't
really have the best upbringing and it's
funny while he's telling this big long
touching story and then they cut across
to the other brother and sister and
they're like
so it's like that it's like touching but
then it's like kind of funny at the same
time but i don't but see only i feel
like only the south koreans
can pull off
that kind of like this tonal thing that
they do it's like it's a really
distinctive as i said i'm sure it's not
all the korean movies but it's just the
ones that i've seen like ones that get
like a big foothold over here like in
the west
i kind of feel like they're very good at
balancing
tones where i feel like if you tried to
do it in the us movie i don't think it
would work out as well like i have seen
some
kind of you know ones like american
films or british films where they did a
similar kind of thing and it worked out
okay but it almost seems like in the
film dna over there like in a weird way
where they're just kind of like yeah
they don't they're not really bound by
the constraints of
genre and it's just like yeah this can
be like horrific and also funny but
those like they're just really good at
balancing and you know and also like
emotionally devastating heartbreaking
and it's like they they don't really
seem to have any they don't seem to have
any problem like mixing those things
together and not thinking it's weird
because it just comes across as very
natural
so it's like i don't know i just really
liked that scene where he was like
sleeping and then you know the dad is
just like telling them he's like come on
give him a break you know he had a
[ __ ] up childhood and he's you know
all this other stuff and they're just
like don't care they're just like bored
it was just kind of that but yeah so uh
so yeah so as i said it's kind of like
as much a story about the monster as it
is about um this family kind of like
coming together
uh and using all their flaws to like
defeat the monster as i said i don't
really want to spoil the ending um other
than you know i guess if i say they
defeat the monster that's kind of
spoiled in the end but i mean other the
other stuff that goes on because it's a
monster movie they usually do get
defeated
so there's that
but uh i also want to say too
this is kind of like this is very
interesting so this movie does have
i don't i wouldn't call it an
anti-american sentiment but it does kind
of have a thing but north korea would
say that because they don't usually
uh praise like south korean movies but
this one they did because they said oh
it's like it's picking on uh the united
states which it kind of does a little
bit but it's almost kind of it picks on
koreans too like you know what i mean so
it's not like just across the board kind
of thing what they're saying is that the
monster was actually caused by because
it was caused by this one military
pathologist um who told this the korean
guy his assistant to dump all these um
you know chemicals in the river and he
did it
and so they are saying yeah america is
ultimately to blame for this monster for
this devastation to our environment but
they're not really letting the koreans
off the hook either because they're like
well you guys went along with it so
you know what i mean and this movie also
portrays the korean government as
very inept um and they don't really give
a [ __ ] about any of their people and
there's a whole thing too where
they leave this ambiguous but the whole
thing remember when i said that they
said oh this uh monster is like uh the
host for a virus and if the monster
touches you and it doesn't eat you like
you'll get this virus and you go to
quarantine and then there's kind of like
a thing later where
somebody tells gang do or he overhears
it like while he's in
uh when he's in custody because he gets
out but then he gets caught again and
they're gonna we need to give him a
lobotomy and all this other stuff he
overhears or one of the guys one of the
scientists an american scientist tells
him oh the virus isn't real we just made
that up but you don't really know if
that's the case so you don't really know
if there's like a virus or not so there
is kind of like a um
a thing too about
misinformation about like maybe
the u.s um you know told the korean
government that there was a virus so
they could have their because so they
had their own kind of agenda because
then later on they
send over uh agent yellow obviously like
agent orange so they want to like spray
chemicals all over this monster to kill
it and then there's all these protesters
and stuff where they don't want them to
spray it because they know it's poison
and all this other stuff so there is
like a lot of commentary in there
about the
the the kind of complicated relationship
between the us and south korea
particularly militarily um which i know
a great deal about but you know i know
enough of the
you know of the outside details to kind
of get where they're coming from with
that but as i said it's not
i don't think it's like super
heavy-handed it's there it's in the
background uh the story is mostly about
this family trying to find this little
girl in this sewer and you know trying
to kill this monster and if you want to
take this other stuff like i said it's
just kind of like godzilla being about
you know the dangers of nuclear power
you know nuclear bombs and stuff like
that like making this big mutation so
it's a similar kind of thing i feel like
all of the monster movies asian monster
movies in general do tend to have a
political subtext or
you know or something like that that's
the reason for the monster existing and
this one is no different but as i said
it's still
you know it's not heavy-handed it's not
anything like that this is still like a
really fun
fast-paced uh monster movie and it has
like a lot of stuff that you don't see
in a lot of these types of monster
movies like i said you get to see the
the monster a lot uh it's cgi and it
does look dated but the monster design
is actually really really cool and sort
of actually kind of looks like a real
creature that could exist uh because it
kind of looks like a hybrid between like
a fish amphibian
lizardy kind of thing i don't know if
lizard but i was i'm trying to think of
like some other animal that would have
like an aquatic animal that have a big
ass tail like that maybe it's almost
like a squid tentacle or like an optic
octopus tentacle or something like that
but it kind of looks like something that
could really exist albeit probably not
at that size i actually kind of like
that they made them the monster
smaller like it's bit like i said it's
still big enough to eat you but it's not
so big that it almost becomes an
abstraction you know what i mean it's
very it's very
visceral it can run around like inside a
crowd like you know what i mean it looks
about bust size
so it's still scary but you can still
get a good scale of it and you can see
the whole thing and it's like running
around and stuff and as i said you see
it pretty much
the first few minutes of the film you
see it in broad daylight like all the
time so you always get a good look at it
because it's not really
structured like a like a standard or
like an average monster movie and i
think that works in its favor like i
said it also
has you know a really good like
emotional core to it with
this family kind of coming together
to
you know toward a common goal and like
getting past their past resentments and
even though it has a very bittersweet
ending it's still kind of like uplifting
a little bit in a way like you know what
i mean so
if you haven't seen the host i kind of
feel like most people have probably seen
it by this point if they're into horror
movies but maybe not so if you have seen
it let me know what you thought if you
haven't seen it are you interested in
seeing it do you like this kind of
monster movie do you like korean movies
let me know in the comments and we'll
have a discussion about it so that will
do it for the last review of monster
march next month like i said we're just
gonna go wide open with whatever movies
i feel like doing i'm not gonna do a
theme i don't think i'm gonna do another
theme until june i think in june i'm
gonna do giallo movies um but yeah so
april and may i don't think i'm gonna
have a theme i'm just gonna do whatever
so uh yeah that'll do it for this
flickr's fear and i will see you guys on
the next one
bye